هذه البقره المريضه تعقل بواسطه طائره
مروحيه للعلاج في احد المستشفيات البيطريه
وهذه الاجراس المعلقه في رقاب الابقار
تصنع بعنايه كبيره بشكل يدوي وتباع بمبالغ
مرتفعه للغايه اذا كانت الابقار تقدس
وتعبد في الهند فهنا سويسرا حيث تحظى هذه
الكائنات بمستويات فريده من الرفاهيه
والدلع
بهذه البقعه من العالم التي يحلم الكثيرون
بزيارتها حتى ولو لساعه قليله تربى قطعان
الابقار السويسريه الشهيره وتحظى بقدر
كبير من الرعايه والاهتمام على سفوح جبال
الانف تقتات على الاعشاب والزهور الطبيعيه
في هذه الاجواء الساحره وكانها في منتجع
فاخر من فئه الخمس نجوم
هذه المروحيات على سبيل المثال تم تخصيصها
لتقوم بدور سيارات الاسعاف وتحميل الابقار
الى المراكز البيطريه في حالات المرض او
الاصابه
فاطمه
[موسيقى]
لضمان ارتوائها وعدم اصابتها بالجفاف
حاويات بلاستيكيه ضخمه علقت اسفل
المروحيات لملئ حوضين كبيرين بالماء
وانقاذ الاف الابقار من العطش في مقاطعه
كانتون غرب سويسرا
[موسيقى]
كل هذا الدلال للابقار في سويسرا له ثماره
بالطبع اعداد الابقار تقدر هنا بنحو 700
الف بقره تضر احد اجود انواع الحليب سنويا
وسمعه دلال الابقار في سويسرا لا تقل قدرا
عن سمعتها في صناعه الاجبان والشوكولا حتى
انها باتت تعرف بعاصمه الجبن وعاصمه
الشوكولا في العالم
حليب تلك الابقار المدلله يصنع منه نحو
450 نوعا مختلفا من الجبن السويسري حيث
يستخدم نحو نصف الحليب المنتج في البلاد
في تصنيع الجبن
المواطن السويسري ياكل نحو 22 كيلو جراما
من الجبن سنويا والمطبخ السويسري يزخر
بالاطباق الشهيره التي يدخل فيها الجبن
كمكون رئيسي ومنها الفوندو السويسري
والراكليت وغيرها الكثير بشكل عام ينظر
الى دلال الابقار في سويسرا على انه نوع
من اتقان العمل فلولا هذا الاهتمام الكبير
لانخفضت جوده حليبها وهو المكون الرئيسي
في صناعه الاجبان والشوكولا الفاخره في
البلاد وبالطبع لا تريد سويسرا ان تخسر
سمعتها العالميه في هذين القطاعين